the jurgen experience there's also
a big enthusiasm gap so only 46 percent
of biden supporters strongly support him
66 percent of trump supporters strongly
support him i'm amazed the 46 percent of
biden supporters i think
39 of them are lying yeah most of them
are lying yeah they just hate trump
they like kamala and they hate trump
yeah i think they'd have a better chance
if kamala was on the ticket
in the front i think it was kamala
versus trump that have a better shot
you said it already yourself this is
really just somebody who's not trump
that's the whole mindset right but
kamala harris at least
we call it kamal that's rude it's kamala
is it
kamala kamala well not like the wrestler
from back in the day kamala or
kamala she i think she'd have a better
shot on her own
i don't know because she she got
absolutely obliterated in the primary
yeah but that was because tulsi sank
it's not it wasn't just tulsi she also
went from pretending to be
like a lefty like bernie sanders and
talking about health care for everybody
and then by the end of the campaign
she was begging to for donald trump to
get banned off twitter as if that's some
sort of like principled stand yeah what
was that about she has no political
instincts and the
idiots around her were like hey use this
as your main issue like get them banned
she's just so used to putting people in
jail
she's just sitting in a twitter jail do
you see that weird
conversation she had with rachel maddow
where she pretended to see the fly
on mike pence's head and was laughing
about it but it's so
obvious that it's fake it's the weirdest
conversation
it's so weird did you see when colbert
was asking her about her strong lines of
attack against biden
it was a debate right he's like so you
didn't mean what you were saying
it was a debate and he let her off the
hook
it's like at least [ __ ] us well yeah
you know
don't but give us that that's a that's a
crazy thing imagine a debate
yeah it's like this before i let you go
if
you noticed the flashlights on vice
president pence's head just the time
direction or if that was something that
only
we could see it at home could you see it
sitting next to him watch this look at
this
oh i made that up
look did you have
feelings about like did you have the
instinct to
hard-hitting journalism
[Laughter]
you know
that is i just you know i think that
it's important that we kind of
um find a way all of us to move on
stop that's the fakest laugh i've ever
heard in my life
that's like a producer laugh when you're
doing a sitcom run through and then
jokes
lane max will have so much more
integrity than these people
but here's the thing there's a long
history of flies landing on candidates
in elections or in in debates one land
on hillary didn't want to run on hillary
and debate with
trump and uh there's another one there's
another one in the past
oh [ __ ] it's happened with obama before
too
did it has and i remember alex jones
saying that's evidence that he's a demon
[Music]
he said that anyone that he was like
hillary smells like sulfur that's a yes
yes that's it he said that hillary
smells like soulfriendly people would
have been close to it it's a smell of
sulfur
the guy someone took him saying all
those things
and put it in a song
i did see that it was hilarious there's
a fly it lands on obama's lip
i mean how funny is that it's so weird
it's weird that flies land on people and
debates and then we make a big deal of
it
and that becomes the number one right as
opposed to the substance
the policy of what they're discussing
that's nothing that's boring that fly
lands it on a pence's head he's a piece
of [ __ ]
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love